(whooshing)
- Focused.
- Focus.
- Stay focused.
- Your focus.
- Focused.
- Focus.
- Stay focused.
- Hello believe nation, my
name is Evan Charmichael,
my one word is believe, and
I believe that entrepreneurs
are going to solve all of
the world's major problems.
So to help you on your journey
today we're going to talk about
how you can be focused.
And as always, as you're
watching if you hear something
that really resonates
with you, please leave it
down in the comments below
and put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired,
and when you write it down
it's much more likely to
stick with yourself, as well.
Enjoy.
(inspirational music)
- Everyone in this room
knows how to create.
You're not a manager of your life,
you're a creator of your life
or you wouldn't be in this room.
How do you create your life?
You get hungry for something, don't you?
Who has done something in
your life that once seemed
difficult or impossible and
now it's part of your life?
Who's got something in your
life in this area, say aye.
- [Audience] Aye.
- How did you do it?
You created it three ways.
Number one, you decided there's
something you wanted so bad
that you unleashed all your desire.
You became obsessed with it.
If it was a business, or
a car, or a relationship,
or a transformation in your body,
if there's something you once
envisioned and now it's real
it's cause you didn't just envision it,
you brought so much emotion to it
that now it's in your
life, it was once a dream,
it was once a goal, and
now it's in your life.
How many have something
like that in your lives now,
say aye.
- [Audience] Aye.
- You may take it for granted now,
hopefully not,
but it was once just a vision.
It may have seemed impossible at one time,
so how did you do it?
You started with a concrete
vision of what you wanted
and you focused on it
continuously, didn't you?
Wherever focus goes, energy.
- [Audience] Flows.
- Flows.
You envisioned something,
you got clear about it,
and then you started thinking
about all the reasons
why you wanted it.
You got excited about it.
Said this is what's next for me now.
I want this.
You may have dreamed about
it, thought about it,
talked about it, but when you focus
on something continuously
something magical happens.
You get insights, don't you?
You overhear a conversation
and you hear something
you wouldn't have heard
if you didn't have that
outcome or goal that you wanted so badly.
Who's ever come up with
something, obsessed about it,
didn't even know how to do
it, and it just happened,
and it came together, who's
had that experience, say aye.
- [Audience] Aye.
- So why don't we tap into that power now
for your business and life.
- I realized that to
have the level of success
that I want to have, it's
difficult to spread it out
and do multiple things,
in order to be world class,
and I made a decision, I
want to be world class.
And it takes such a
desperate obsessive focus
to excel on a level that
I want to make movies.
You know, Star Wars, when I was young,
I sat in a movie theater
and watched Star Wars
and I just couldn't believe
that that movie made me
feel like that, just
floored and just stunned
by the creativity.
And just I'm realizing that
in order to move people
in that way, in order to
touch people in that way,
you really got to focus
with all of your fiber,
and all of your heart, and
all of your creativity.
- You want to make your dream come true,
you got to stay focused.
Some people rather get
even than get ahead,
stay focused on where you want to go.
I just kept on doing what
I was supposed to do.
And so I was driving to the radio station,
my opponent had over $20,000,
I had less than $800.
As I was in the radio
station, the guy said,
you're going to make a
commercial, I said yes.
He said, it better be a
good one because that money
can't go pretty far here.
(audience laughs)
And I sat there in the middle control room
and I was thinking.
And here's what happens
when you get still.
Stuff will start coming.
Something said, call your
mom, you use to talk about
your mother on the air all the time,
ask her to say a few words for you,
that'll be a different
kind of political spot.
(audience laughs)
So I called my mom and I
had a gospel record playing
in the background.
(audience laughs and applauds)
And then I had my mother say,
hello, this is Mrs. Brown,
when I raised my sons I raised
them to be good children,
when they got out of
hand I beat their behind
and made them go right,
please vote for my son, he's a good boy.
(audience laughs and applauds)
Usually in a state representative race
maybe three or four thousand
people will come out
to vote in a primary.
And that primary race over 27,000 people
came out and voted and said,
I'm voting for Les Brown
cause his mother say
he's a good boy. (laughs)
(audience laughs and applauds)
I won, ladies and gentlemen.
I won.
(audience applauds)
So you've got to be
willing to stay focused,
to be creative, to be relentless,
because things are going to happen to you
when you're working on your dream.
- What kinds of business
ideas have you said no to?
- I'm saying no to a lot of ideas
because as a CEO I have to
say no to opportunities,
because if I say yes, I
probably get 5,000 opportunities
every day, but whether yes
or no, everything based on
the mission that we're
helping doing business easier,
it's on that we will consider.
If somebody come and
say, can you, we will,
you know, have business deal,
we'll make a lot of money,
I'm not interested.
- It's easy to discard,
say, 10 terrible ideas
and go after the one good idea,
but when you start to get
a little bit of momentum
you can drown yourself
in good opportunities
that aren't great opportunities.
And if you scatter your
focus, you try to do
17 different product lines,
you can kill your business
really easily, particularly
when you have a small team.
So I think asking yourself
repeatedly, what is the one
project, the one initiative,
the one campaign that
if successful will render
the rest of these things
either unnecessary or much, much easier,
what is that one step?
And I've called it this
dead domino before,
but what is the one thing on
this list of seven different
campaigns that will
make all the other ones
irrelevant or much easier?
- How do you, I mean, that's
a tough answer, isn't it?
Because they all sound good.
- Yeah, I think they can,
and I think that what it
comes down to often times is,
it returns back to
measurements, so how are we
defining success, like if
we want to grow the company,
let's just say, what does that mean,
in three months, six months,
what are we measuring,
why are we measuring those things,
and what is a, sort of a comfort goal,
meaning like, okay, we think
we can easily hit this number,
what is a stretch, and what is like,
hallelujah, we threaded our needle,
and then come up with a really
concrete number to tackle,
and once you have that
number then you can look
at those five and say,
alright, which of those
are going to serve us right now.
And I'm dealing with that increasingly so
because out of all these
different branches of content,
and activities, and angel
investing, and so on,
it's very easy for me to get scattered,
it's never been easier,
so I have to continually
ask that type of question.
- What's your main focus now,
if you had to boil it down to one?
- My main focus right now is
building my podcast, Tim Ferriss
Show, up to a point where
it's consistently in the top
10 to 15 on iTunes so that
I can establish a presence
and name recognition
in Hollywood and entertainment,
which I can leverage then
for the TV show and film
projects that I'll be
expanding into in the
next three to nine months.
And specifically what that
means is targeted advertising,
for the podcast, specifically
towards people who are
producers, agents, actors, directors,
in Hollywood and New York City,
all of that can be quantified.
- The one thing that I feel deeply about,
and this is something
I'll feel deeply about
when I leave government is
stuff gets better if we work at it
and we stay focused on where we're going.
It doesn't immediately get all solved,
and I warned against this
when I was running for office
because everybody had the Hope posters,
and the this, and the that, and everybody
was feeling like, man.
- Hey, we didn't make
those, you made those.
(audience laughs)
Quit blaming us.
- No, no, no, no, no.
- That wasn't us, was it?
- Hold on a second, no, no,
no, I like the poster.
- I'm pretty sure that came from you.
- It was a nice poster.
No, but what I'm saying is is that
if you look at what I
said at the time, I said,
this is going to be an ongoing project,
and it's a project of citizens.
It's not just, fix it.
It's how do we work
together to get things done,
and it will be imperfect,
but over time is it better?
And here's the thing I can say, John,
I can say this unequivocally,
the VA is better now than
when I came into office,
it is better now than
when I came into office.
Government works better than
The economy, by every metric, is better
than when I came into office.
And so the reason I can sleep
at night is I say to myself,
(audience applauds)
you know what, it's better.
Now, am I satisfied with it, no.
And should voters be satisfied with it?
Absolutely not because
otherwise if we get complacent
and lazy then stuff doesn't happen.
- Losing focus is another way
that founders get off track.
I actually think this
is a symptom of burnout.
When you get really burned
out on running the business
you want to do easier things,
or sort of more gratifying things.
You want to go to
conferences and have people
tell you how great you are.
You want to do all these
things that are not actually
building the business, and
the most common post YC
failure case for the companies
we fund is that they're incredibly focused
during a YC on their
company, and then after
they start doing a lot of other things.
They advise companies, they
go to conferences, whatever.
Focus is what made you
successful in the first place.
There are a lot of
reasons people lose focus,
but fight against that
really, really hard.
- But the reason I made
it is because I knew
exactly what I wanted to do,
see that's the thing I see
with a lot of people
nowadays, they be confused,
like they don't really
have a clear cut, concise
goal in mind, or they
don't have that one thing
that they feel that they're good at,
so they don't try to master it.
Like I'm reading a book right now called
The Mastery by Robert Greene,
and it's basically taking
that whole 10,000 hour theory,
like you're not a master
in something until you've
put in 10,000 hours in it.
- Practice worth 10,000 hours.
- Yeah, so it's like you
got to find that one thing
to put in that time
with, and everything else
will sprout from it, like
radio was my thing, then I'm.
- So what you're saying is that
you always knew then radio,
like once it clicked.
- Always, man.
- I don't know, you know, I've
tried to keep my focus on
the music that I was making.
I tried not to get distracted.
I had a lot of
models who came before
me where I could see
where people made mistakes,
and nobody's perfect,
you make mistakes, you know, and,
you know, it's just a part of
human life, but I think that,
that the kind of mistakes
where you lose your center
and you lose track of the
work that you're doing
and the music you're making, and you lose,
you lose the ability to
be relevant to your fans,
and to the community
that you're working for.
I've just done my best
with them, you know,
I'd be the last person to claim any,
make any claim on getting it
completely right or perfect,
but I've tried to do
it well enough to where
I continue to have a voice for my fans
and I'm able to look into the world
and experience and translate what I see
in a productive fashion.
- Well, when you're doing
a TV show, you know,
every day is a different
day in the sense that
it's never the same, and you
might be shooting two scenes,
you might have one scene,
you might have five scenes.
So your level of preparation
is different every time.
Generally, I'm up early,
I exercise, I run,
I do whatever it is that I'm doing
in terms of my physical life,
other than playing tennis
which I, I stack up during
the course of a week
quite a lot of, if I can,
and, you know, get to set,
depending on your call time,
and very often it's very early.
And then you try to
be there and be alert,
and awake, and alive,
and ready to go every hour of the day.
And if you work 12 hours
then you have to be
alert every one of those hours.
It's an important thing to stay focused.
- Thank you guys so much for watching,
I hope you enjoyed, I'd love
to know what did you take
from this video that you
are going to immediately now
apply to your life or
your business somehow,
please leave it down
in the comments below,
I'm really curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Derrick Cui,
hope I pronounced that okay,
Derrick thank you so much
for picking up a copy of
my book, Your One Word,
I really, really, really
appreciate the support, man,
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
So thank you guys again for watching,
I believe in you, I hope you
continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is,
much love, I'll see you soon.
(whooshing)